hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of ask GameSpot the show where
you brave and we default what does that
mean exactly I'm not sure but luckily
Peter Browns here to tell us all about a
little game called bravely default our
first question comes via Facebook from
Andres who wants to know
Peter why does this game feel more Final
Fantasy ish then all the other Final
Fantasies combined maybe you remember
Final Fantasy games of old right where
you had Wizards you had warriors
although they were called mages and
Knights and well so lately Final Fantasy
games have been set in some weird future
scapes and it's not really the way it
used to be bravely default goes back to
that mix of medieval times and a little
bit of the Renaissance thrown in you
know it just kind of captures that
fantasy feel yeah I noticed during the
demo there wasn't one like super emo
protagonist and I didn't go through one
futuristic motorcycle battle exactly
yeah and it's got a lot of other things
in it too like you know terminology like
Phoenix down yeah the names that they
use for spells it's apart from the title
basically a Final Fantasy and the guys
who have made it we're also the guys who
worked on the four heroes of light on
the DS it's basically a spiritual
successor to that game Christopher on
Facebook wants to know is the grinding
in this game gonna be super boring like
it is in most JRPGs grinding is
inherently boring you know a little bit
just a little what bravely default has a
few settings that help speed up the
process you can change the encounter
rate so when you're running around the
world map the run into enemies more
frequently or less frequently depending
on what you're trying to do you can also
speed up the battle animations as well
up to four times standard speed so that
way you can get through a battle in just
a couple of seconds where before it
would have taken me maybe 30 seconds or
a whole minute the game also has these
bonus objectives that ever give you like
if you can played a battle in one round
or don't take any damage I've also give
you some experience ER or JP points yeah
so that's just a little extra incentive
to keep those random battles footage
all right so Morris on Facebook wants to
know are we getting the original version
of bravely default or this slightly
easier version that he's heard some
rumors about it she has a little
confused but he's kind of on the right
path there are two versions of Rayleigh
default in Japan there was the first one
called bravely default flying fairy okay
which is the title of our game but our
game is based on bravely default for the
sequel for the sequel incorporated fan
feedback to help shape the game for
future titles in the series that's the
version of the game we got even though
the subtitle is flying fairy but it's
not necessarily easier although if you
find yourself in a particularly
challenging battle you do have the
option to lower the difficult Krystal
McGee Viator tur wants to know is there
gonna be an option for having Japanese
subtitles in English poison or vice
versa I probably said that backward no
actually no no but you're right though
okay yeah you have the option of having
Japanese voices English voices English
subtitles or Japanese subtitles I don't
know why you would want the Japanese
subs I think the takeaway here is that a
lot if you're trying to you know teach
yourself you get a word lines up with an
image because you know that the English
and Japanese sentence structures are
exactly the same
that's just audio anyway people who like
Japanese RPGs often prefer the Japanese
audio track
okay I'm for very different reasons but
that's what you want you have the option
to do that in bravely default
it stupendous man on Twitter and I feel
like that's not your real name but he
wants to know is the story and bravely
v4 gonna be any good or is it just
typical JRPG nonsense I can't make the
call that's gonna be good or not but it
is very reminiscent of older Final
Fantasy games there are four young
heroes there are gonna go on a mystical
quest there are crystals that they have
to somehow save to save the world um
it's it's not a really interesting brand
new story but the characters themselves
aren't that bad from what I've played
and I for me it's really about the
gameplay okay and the world the story is
secondary I know that's not always the
case with RPGs for a lot of people but
for me it is and I don't know i think
bravely default is just fine the way it
is my folks thanks again for watching
another episode of ask GameSpot if you
want to know more about bravely default
our UK team recently finished up a
review for the international version of
the game otherwise if you want to get
your hands on the game itself Peter
when's it coming out February 7th
alright well thanks again for coming and
sharing your bravely default knowledge
with the folks at home was a play
you